we're gonna start with some breaking
news concerning the Royal baby archie
harrison mountbatten-windsor his birth
certificate has been released and it
confirms that the Dutchess of Sussex
gave birth to her first child Archie at
the private Portland Hospital in
Westminster they've been much
speculation about whether he was born at
home at Frogmore cottage in windsor or
whether he was indeed born at the
Portland hospital in central London and
well the birth certificate confirms that
it was there the place of birth listed
as the Portland Hospital he arrived at
526 a.m. on the 6th of May weighing 7
pounds 3 ounces Megan gave her name is
Rachel Megan her Royal Highness the
Duchess of Sussex and listed her
occupation as Princess of the United
Kingdom most of the details of course we
knew but the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
have been fairly secretive about where
Archie had been born confirmed now that
he was born at the Portland Hospital
private hospital in central London